[Music]
all right so how many guys have done
conducted business over zoom or Skype so
far yeah a lot yeah or like
live-streaming or taking what we
normally do and take it on to a platform
to keep making money or keep progressing
our lives right yeah man I think I want
to do that post quarantine yeah makes so
much play on offense really yeah what
would you do [ __ ] or just like I know
girls are just getting into it right and
they're not huge they hit maybe have a
20,000 followers and imagine you had a
lot of followers right but they're
making like like 6,000 10,000 a month by
doing nothing to leave I mean we do mean
nothing like you mean like showing a
[ __ ] no they don't even have to they
just show like my friend is dead and
she's just like twerking or she's just
like so that's a little bit more extreme
there's girls that just show like the
same photos that they would do on
Instagram just a little bit more like
different positions little stuff that
didn't make it a little more sideboob
but yeah but no a better composition you
think more foreground elements a lot of
like fog refers that want to get out
there they don't have the platform or
Instagram I see but they're making so
much [ __ ] money can you cap course
mate capita has their like a watermark
on it now so the minute so if you try to
like I guess cuz only fans works because
you can't get this secret content
anywhere else right so you have to pay
no you can't but it's a if they have
lawyers and everything it's legal to
take someone else's content from there
and post on another site but isn't it
already too like let's say let's say I'm
a big fan of you yeah right and I really
want to jack off to you really bad yeah
so I found out you got fans only only
fans whatever so I'm paying this month B
so I can jack off to you whenever I want
and but like let's say for a whole month
I've been screen capping all of your all
of your photos yeah now I have my
material I don't need to pay for what
new [ __ ] you get tired of the old title
- so you're a customer yes absolutely
you can't just a material I have some
favorites yeah like Dallas toured and
you're like going visible to like it's
like looking at an old friend you know
yeah
I wonder how they're doing like in real
life you know because sometimes they're
not that popular yeah but it's like the
same thing it's like okay like you pay
for Netflix right and then this movie
comes out on your screen record it and I
gotta say then you don't pay for Netflix
anymore
now you gotta just watch that saying oh
I don't want something want something
else nice it's so funny because there's
a lot of like sex workers on Twitter
right and then I don't know why they
keep popping up on my feet I think it's
like Gina liking what they say or some
[ __ ] right but this one girl was like
nothing to be that you follow you know i
don't follow him that's why i pop by
twitter too cuz i follow Gina there's a
bunch of like see that's what it is cuz
gina follows them and i don't know she
has friends and we had like one person
we mutually followed but other than that
it was I don't follow uh cam grows and
stuff but anyways cam girls keep popping
up on my feet
one cam girl was like so you told me to
get a more realistic job and boom she
posted her only fans account thing right
this girl was making like 20 grand a
month and then it showed her annual
revenue it was well like into the nice
six-figure mark so you're telling me to
get a serious a job like what you know
like yeah come on man yeah making there
making so much money now that is the
serious job they're the ones working
consistently then you know and they're
beating the [ __ ] up like every week
like damn that's up that's a serious job
cuz you don't need a post that stuff
really you don't you might tease right
people are like this is how much money I
mean how I met a screen recorder what
they actually posted and it just like
feed pigs or random stuff but it's just
like people subscribe because you can't
see you until you subscribe either but
sometimes people just like that can guys
make the same amount not probably not I
feel like I have I feel like gay guys
will buy more than the wind fan women
straight women true I don't think women
are turned on the same way that we're
thinking whoa I understand my own
biology I'm like I take
you go on Twitter you see a lot of girls
subscribing to the girls to support them
oh okay Dan so girls get support from
girls and guy yeah
damn girls are so supportive that was
like this dad subscribe to her daughter
to support it all the best I know Jenna
Jameson's dad used to go on the old
school porn star uh-huh her dad used to
go on set to support her weird power
he's is awareness whatever dad was
getting pounded okay so because I'm just
picturing it this way right like so if
my son was a porn star would I be
freaked out at that nah if my daughter
was it will freak me out because I'm
imagining a mini version of my wife
getting [ __ ] that's where my brain
goes really yeah if it's a guy if it's a
boy it's like mini-me [ __ ] so I'm
like that's right what if it's many what
it's many you getting [ __ ] in the ass
oh if it's gay porn yeah I don't know
about that okay but if it's if it's like
meaning me I see you miniature me but
what if my daughter looked like me and
my [ __ ] son look like my wife he'll
be like Will Smith and Jada Pinkett like
how will they lose my girls man
Jayda yeah well okay in my imagination
what I'm assuming is it's a mini version
of me or a younger version of myself
banging girls and I'm nice cheering them
on you like yeah me do what I could
never do and if it's my daughter I'm
like dude that's like young wife like
what are you doing no I don't know
alright anyways wait I called my
daughter my wife that's [ __ ] weird
where are you doing I still can't relate
today - alright so anyways speaking of
real jobs real jobs like I guess like
normal jobs like 9:00 to 5:00 and stuff
and like office jobs and then also
classrooms like you know universal
classrooms or even like middle school
high school a lot of these zoom sessions
are being hijacked these days hi John I
heard about that hijacked like as in
like people will come on like those know
somehow hack into the sessions and
they'll start if there is like a black
dude or an Asian dude excited hate
speech or during a speech all over like
they'll type it into the forums and
stuff
they're sending porn into classrooms and
like and now the FBI has issued a
warning to the public about these
hijackings and I read it what's the
warning don't do it don't do it
yes hackers like okay if the news like
really wants something to stop this [ __ ]
report on it cuz now you open it to a
much more people my old assumed to be
like oh we gotta increase our security
because if Noah knows about a doom is
like oh it's not a big deal guys but if
it makes yeah they're like what do we do
my old roommates were they just did a
prank with that and it was funny but
it's kind of [ __ ] out because you were
[ __ ] up a lecture and these people
that still need to go to school and
everything but they were joining the
class and asked the dumbest questions to
the teachers because they were doing the
pranks where they go into classes and
ass like stupid things we start drinking
yeah they're doing the same thing not
it's funny but then it's also like
stupid like these are people that
actually meet you but they're they're
trying to be invented with the times -
like all the way
they can prank now it's like going
through like these in college we gotta
pick the classrooms to zoom now that's
[ __ ] hilarious are calling this zoom
bombing zoom bombings that they had
always have to put the word bombing and
everything that they don't like
yeah it's called zoom bombing and yeah
races in vile language putting porn into
things and then a lot of a lot a lot of
these hijackers are also like displaying
their tattoos and like I guess for
example like swastika tattoos and stuff
so I just very just like extremists are
hopping onto this trend and they're
trying to zoom bomb all sorts of things
right now it sounds like a Boomer made
that phrase zoom bum zu mom they're like
oh he just got Zoom bombed oh yeah I
mean say Gog and then all the kids are
like let's not call it that yeah well
you know I have seen on Zoom where
there's a feature we can kind of kick
someone out or like mute them or like
not show their camera angle I feel like
the thing I've been seeing a lot is
because a lot of these professors are
older and they're just getting used to
the technology because they're switching
from just give me a lecture in front of
kids to now having to hold the whole
thing where you see like all the kids
like just like there's was a video
modeling a few days ago or this kids
like smoking and like showing off his
money blasting music and I was a cute in
the class yeah I was like [ __ ] this and
like just vibing out right yeah and then
that the teachers like trying to kick
him up the teat all the kids are like
just kick him out you might he's like
I'm trying and he can't figure it out he
alone has the power for the whole class
right doesn't know how to use yeah it's
like the center when you when you move
your cursor over to like that person's
window like it'll give you those two
options nobody said you might not even
know how to do that because you always
see like the funny videos where they're
like trying to forget it sit on can you
hear me or get high and then they're all
I can see those like oh yeah you so
there you go away hey why doesn't the
[ __ ] school have a session for all
the professors like what the [ __ ] good I
don't blame them because have you seen
bar or Steve use a phone
he's like why is my tech specialist
coming in three times yeah you're gonna
be the target for zoom bombing that's
like how to use your space yeah ask me
Isaac and say hey Isaac can you uh can
you help me with the Xbox like I'm
already entered I do not know how to put
on put on NBA 2k by myself dude oh my
god I'm like alright guys if you didn't
play Minecraft let me hop on real quick
and I'll be like I'll be on the on the
Xbox like whatever your clothes screamed
at the home screen I'm like who the [ __ ]
are the games like I see like [ __ ]
all these other things in like updates
and stuff but no games and now I'm like
what the [ __ ] back in the day when I
least live in like the baryon was around
family and my little cousin was doing
homework and II was confused so you
asked me for help somewhere okay I'll
help you out and I get to it I'm like
why the [ __ ] are they teaching those
kids this and I'm like I couldn't even
figure it out so me and him we're both
strong I feel like he was kind of
teaching me like the formula that goes
into it and then I could teach him yeah
but maybe that's more beneficial to him
you know cuz you kind of learn things
better buddy Perot
remember he knew you're a dummy I figure
we're teaching worship Oh
[Laughter]
my mom told I'm like hey just to help a
movie dad one example of the zoom
bombing stuff was a Korean lady in
Detroit who she was teaching a dance
class and she got Zoom bombed and then
she was she the the hackers I guess were
calling her a lot of derogatory names
and stuff like that and she's only been
in the States for at least 7 years and
it was the first time she's ever been
like in a racist situation and she just
didn't know how to deal with it and like
for her it was just like a rude
awakening of like that ugly side of
America yeah cuz usually with like she
should just go on 4chan then people that
are races might not say it in person
they might talk to her
it's all through video games it's all
through online tags where they have that
that that barrier yeah
but now they still feel that like now
they might see their face but they still
feel that bear that it's not I can't
feel the repercussions no no no so like
my friend she went to like a grocery
store like maybe like a browse in
Pasadena or something and um she she
walked into the store and she sees this
like white dude like literally berating
these like like Asian this asian couple
would be like what the [ __ ] are you
doing here like you should go back to
your own country and like I think they
were Fox cuz they couldn't really speak
English very well but then like they
were [ __ ] scared because they're like
holy [ __ ] this guy's like yelling at me
and why not and then like they always
pick on people that don't fight back
though yeah I never get that [ __ ] me
neither yeah and so then my friend
walked up and then the guy was like see
look do both applying and then she was
like [ __ ] so she started like yeah I
feel like he was getting like hysterical
and then there's like security guards I
like what like came in and then like the
guy was like dude you gotta take these
people out this shouldn't be in like
this grocery store and then my friend
was like what the [ __ ] like well first
of all you know [ __ ] is like I can be
here I need get groceries and blah blah
blah and then like the bush cop with him
cause I know that's so funny then you
look bad
you can't cough on people no no no don't
care my therapist you know he's like oh
I don't feel so good yeah accident no no
no it so happens in person but there's
also that side of like the people
because those like older people that are
being raised this way great so like this
dude like was so riled up that he
actually pushed a security guard and
this guy is like [ __ ] huge and he was
like all right dude you get one and he
was like come on God just on me about it
I was like if you push me again I'm
probably gonna let this lady behind me
[ __ ] kick your ass my friend was like
[ __ ] pissed and then later the cops
came up and they're like they got like
they arrested him put him in the back
seat of the car he's like what did I do
no goddamn better and [ __ ] my
friend told the couple's like oh you
should file like a police report like
yeah and a hate crime
yeah exactly for harassment I don't
think like they wanted they didn't know
English they just never see an immigrant
you don't wanna I want a bus and I claim
this be like these [ __ ] chicks out
here you're right you should have been
next to that's right brother [ __ ] with
this head saw the best reverse [ __ ]
you would be like lady why don't you
agree with you you know why let's not
that for let's not take it might be here
oh my god dude we should do that like to
flip it on them that means my good day
[Music]